Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
Show. I'm producer Pat Forde, filling in
for David today as he continues his paternity
leave. We're now finding out more having to do
with you of all the shooting that took place a few
weeks ago and specifically the police department's
failed response to it. We're now finding out that
they're working with a private law firm to prevent
the release of details to the public as to what
exactly they were doing as a gunman was inside
Rob Elementary School murdering 19 children and
two teachers. We already knew that their story had
changed a bunch, and we knew that they hesitated.
There was a dispute over when exactly they arrived
and whether they confronted the shooter at the
door, whether that door was propped open by
a teacher. But at the very least, it was clear
from early on that they didn't follow protocol,
that they waited and waited, and they didn't want
to go into the school out of fear for their own
lives, and that they even went so far as to hold
back parents who were trying to go in and save
their kids, knowing that the cops weren't
going to do anything for them. In addition,
we found out this week that cops were in the
hallway of the school but refused to advance,
even though they certainly had the proper
equipment, the rifles and the guards and
the shields and everything that you would need to
confront the shooter. And they were also spending
spending a bunch of time trying to find a key
to the classroom that the shooter was hiding in,
even though the door was unlocked the entire
time. So they didn't need a key. So now the police
department wants to make sure nothing more gets
out. The public records they're trying to hide,
which include the body camera footage, the
photos, 911 calls, emails, text messages.
They're trying to hide all of it. A letter from
the city to Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton
says that the department doesn't want to release
the information because for one, it's being sued,
which is somewhat understandable, I guess, but
also because it includes highly embarrassing
information and that the info is not of legitimate
concern to the public. So how brazen can they be?
They're out now admitting that what's in the
documents is embarrassing, meaning that they
did wrong, that they knew that they did wrong,
and that it's just not important, apparently,
for the public to learn about, even though this
is a matter having to do with the deaths of 21
people in the community, many of them little
kids. And you're going to say that it's of no
concern to the public. How can you get away with
saying something like that? The city and its
police department argue it should be exempted
from releasing police officer training guides,
police policy and procedure manuals, shift change
schedules, security details and blueprints of
secured facilities. Because these could be used
to decipher methods, techniques and strategies
for preventing and predicting crime. Well, okay,
to some degree I understand this one. But clearly,
whatever methods, techniques and strategies they
had ahead of this mass shooting, they either
didn't work or they didn't follow them. They chose
not to use them. And so it would be nice to review
the process and see how we could go about changing
it. So this is going to be a travesty if they're
allowed to block the documents from public view,
especially because they've already been caught
in so many lies. And the public has a right to
know about this stuff, right? Because it's their
tax dollars that were being spent and it was their
community that was ultimately hurt by all of this
and hurt by their failed response. And this
is a situation that probably should lead to
some criminal charges. I'm not saying that you
should charge the entire police department,
but certainly the officers who were there who
had the opportunity to go in and decided not to.
Many of them should be charged with child neglect.
That's what happened to that officer in Parkland
who refused to go into the school. That should
probably happen to many of the officers who were
on scene there. And at the very least, many of
those cops should be losing their jobs because not
only did those who followed the police officers
fail, those 21 victims and their families,
not only did they fail to involve the community,
they also failed society at large, like the public
needs to be able to trust that if it hits the
fan, the cops are going to be there around the
corner to protect them. That's why police officers
get the respect and the reverence that they do
among most people in the country because they're
believed to be putting their lives on the line.
You can't have a situation where the community
views cops is just the people who are out there
giving traffic tickets or breaking up high school
parties, acting like tough guys in so doing,
but then not step in when a situation
like this really calls for it,
really calls for police attention. So let's
cross our fingers and hope that this effort
to block the body cam footage and the text
and all the other relevant information isn't
successful because the public deserves to know
about this. Right. And these cops need to be
held accountable for their dereliction of
duty, not just in response to the specific
shooting and the 21 victims, but also for the
ramifications that it has for society at large.